So U being unitary is equivalent to the columns forming an orthonormal set,
And that has to be a basis because the number of vectors in the set, which is three in this case, agrees with the dimension of the space
that we're working in. You can follow a similar argument for the rows instead of the columns to conclude that U being
unitary is equivalent
to the rows farming an orthonormal basis.
It doesn't work quite as nicely because we have to make an adjustment to get the complex conjugates
to work in the right way, but the idea is the same.
An alternative way to go about it, which is pretty straightforward, is to prove that a matrix is unitary if and only if it's transposed as unitary.
And here I do mean to say transpose and not conjugate transpose.
It's pretty trivial from the
definition of unitary matrices, that the conjugate transpose
of any unitary matrix is unitary,
but it's also the case that the transpose of any unitary matrix is unitary.
In any case, we have the
equivalence between these three conditions on any square matrix U, and we can combine this equivalence
with the fact about
extending orthonormal sets to form orthonormal bases in order to come up with unitary matrices
that do interesting things
or fulfill various needs that we may encounter.
Specifically anytime we
have an orthonormal set of M vectors, there will always exist a unitary matrix U
whose first M columns are the vectors from that orthonormal set.
The remaining columns
can always be filled in so that we obtain a unitary matrix by choosing them so that the columns form
an orthonormal basis. This will be a pretty
handy fact for us to have at our disposal.
And one more topic for
this section of the lesson is the notion of a projection.
A square matrix Pi is
said to be a projection or a projection matrix if the two properties that
are listed here are both true.
This is a capital Pi by the way, it's a pretty typical choice for a letter that's used to denote a projection.
We often give these typical sorts of names to objects such as matrices just to make them easier to recognize and keep things straight,
but you could use whatever name you like. Anyway, the first condition is that Pi is equal to its own conjugate transpose.
In general, when we have a matrix that's equal to its own
conjugate transpose, we say that it's a Hermitian matrix.
So the first condition can alternatively be stated as Pi is Hermitian.
The second condition is
that if we square Pi, meaning that we multiply Pi
to itself, we get Pi again.
So squaring Pi doesn't do anything to it.
The idea of a projection
intuitively speaking is that it's similar in
spirit to projecting an image onto a screen or dropping
a perpendicular onto a line
for instance. When you multiply a
vector by a projection, what you're doing is in some sense
leaving a part of it alone
and zeroing out the rest.
So if you apply a
projection a second time, it doesn't do anything because
you've already zeroed out the part that the projection zeroes out.
An example of a projection
is this matrix right here for any choice of a unit vector Psi.
We can check that it satisfies
the required conditions one at a time.
For the first one, we compute
the conjugate transpose and this is the conjugate
transpose of a product.
And so we can use this formula right here for the conjugate transpose
of a product to help us.
What you get is the product
of the conjugate transposes, but the order gets reversed.
That happens because of
the transposition part.
So if we apply that formula, we obtain this equality right here and we can then simplify to
get back the original matrix.
Notice by the way, that we didn't use the fact
that Psi is a unit vector.
So in fact, this matrix is
Hermitian for any vector Psi, not just for unit vectors.
And for the second one, we square Pi and we obtain
this expression right here and that is equal to the
original matrix this time
because Psi is a unit vector, so this inner product
right here is equal to one and that's where the assumption
that Psi is a unit vector
comes into play.
We can generalize this example and start with an orthonormal set.
And if we form this matrix right here, where we sum up the projections corresponding to the individual vectors, then we obtain a projection.
Here on the screen, you can see calculations that reveal that and I'll leave it to you to
examine them if you wish.
And along similar lines
to the first example, it's the second condition where the orthonormality
of the set gets used.
What this projection does if
you multiply it to a vector, is to project that
vector onto the subspace that's spanned by this set of vectors,
which in an abstract way is
like dropping a perpendicular to that subspace, and once
you're in that subspace, the projection doesn't do anything.
So matrices like this are
examples of projections, and now in fact we've exhausted
all of the possibilities.
Every projection matrix takes this form for some choice of an orthonormal set.
The zero matrix is a projection, so we do have to make
sure we include that one if we want to get every projection.